مشاهدينا نذكركم بالطفله التي ولدت تحت
الركام في جنديرس في سوريا بينما توفيت
والدتها وابوها واخوتها الاربعه نجح
المنقذون في اخراجها لتعيش كشاهد على هذه
الماساه التي تعيشها سوريا
ينضم الينا عبر سكايب من جنديرس خليل شامي
اسود منقذ هذه الرضيعه التي نذكر انها
ولدت تحت الانقاض والقريب الوحيد المتبقي
لها بعد ان توفي جميع افراد عائلتها اهلا
وسهلا بك سيد خليل يعني يعطيك الف عافيه
وحمد لله على سلامتك وسلامه هذه
الطفله اخبرنا عن هذه اللحظه اللحظات يعني
انت الفرد الوحيد المتبقي لهذه الرضيعه
نعم
اخبرنا عن لحظات انقاذك لها
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله اهلا
انسه ساره زلزال بال 17 دقيقه تقريبا هيك
تسمعين
صارت الاعتزال تقريبا زلزال صار بالاربعه
وسبعه عشر دقيقه بلش ثلاث دقائق ونص
تقريبا فهو ابو ردينه الله يرحمه ابن عمي
وانا اخذ اخته وهو جاري بسدي كان ساكن
فصار الزلزال انا كنت فايق ما اجى لعندي
فاختو قالت لي ابو ردينه قلت لها ابو
ردينه الله يرحمه راح من ما اجى راح الله
يرحمه فطلعت من البيت
البنايه اللي بسدين هدت على البيت فاتت
القبر كلها عندنا على البيت فطلعت انا
اركض من البيت كان ابن عمي ساكن مسدس
قال الشباب قلت له راحوا الشباب فبلشت
انادي ابو ردينه ابو ردينه ما رد علي
هون كانت الجو تمطر وكذا تعب وبرد انا
بردت كتير كنت قاعد على النار مشغلين
الشباب نار فنادولي صاحب الباجر قال لي
تعال شوف الحرمه هاي تتعرف عليها هي هي عم
تدور لها فجيت لعندك قلت له نعم هاي ام
ردينه واحنا عم نحفر
بايدي صرت احفر مشان ما يسوون وكذا سمعت
الصوت من فرحتي والشده بلشت اصرخ واصيح
قلت لهم ابو ردينه عايش ابو ردينه شلت
التراب ان الطفل طلع طفل هو فكانت تراب
كله على وجهه وكل جسمه يعني فشلته وطلع
طفل قطعنا الحبل تبع الصره بالموس
وقلت انا الله يرحمه ابو ردينه راح هو
وعيلته اريد انقذ الطفله ورحنا به على
مشفى بعفرين مشفى جيهان وحطيتها بالمشفى
هونيك ورجعت لعند ابوها وامها كفينا ضلينا
نحفر حتى طلعت ابوها وامها واخواتها
ودفناهم
بالمستشفى المستشفى جيهان بالحضانه ووضعها
منيح في صدرها في كسره ضلعين مكسورات نعم
وباقي اعضاء سليمه
سليمه الحمد لله ما فيها شيء طيب
لاحقا هذه الفتاه يعني
اخسر الوحيد اللي
اقاربها او جيرانها مع من ستبقى هذه
الطفله هل هنالك من معلومات حول لمن ستعطى
بدها تضل عندي لانه عمتها انا ياخذ عمتها
يعني وانا ابن عم ابوها يعني بدها تضل
عندي التربه
طيب يعني عائلتك انت كلها بخير يعني كل
افراد عائلتك نجو من هذا الزلزال
ايه الحمد لله انا طيب وصف لنا الوضع
بجنديرس سيد خليل يعني هذه
المدينه نالت النصيب الاكبر من الضحايا
ومن الخراب والدمار
نعم الوضع اول نهار يعني كان ماساوي كتير
ماساوي
يعني شلون ما اقول لك ماساوي ماساوي لا في
معدات لا شيء عم اقول لك هذول اصدقائي
يحيى النشمي وعهد العماد الله يجزيهم
الخير بعثوا فوق العشر اليات وبلشوا
يساعدوا العالم مو بس لعندي يعني لكل
جنديرس يعني لكل العالم عم يساعدوها
بس
ادويه ودول هكذا ما دخلت نهائيا اللي جاي
هلا صار في مساعدات عم يبعثوا بس عم
يبعثوا حرامات وبطانيات ما امشي العالم ما
في عندها ماوى لا في عم يعملوا مخيمات لا
عم يعملوا سكني للعالم هلا انا وعائلتي ما
في عندنا مكان اللي نجينا ما في مكان
عملناهم بالسياره
طيب سيد خليل يعني هل تلقيت ربما عروض او
مساعدات من اجل الطفله الرضيعه لانه قصتها
اثرت بالعديد من الاشخاص
لا لحتى الان هلا من شويه تواصلوا معي
اشخاص قالوا احنا نتكفل بنت مشان حليب
وحفاضات وما قلت لهم ما بدنا يعني الله
يجزيكم الخير طبعا اشخاص هون يعني
وعلي
اي عائله ان تتبناها هل يمكن ان تقبل لا
مستحيل انا بقطع من لحمي واطعميها ما
بعطيها هل اعطيت اسم
اعطيته سمعته على اسم
ان شاء الله عفره تضل بصحتها طيب تحدثت
انه حتى الان لم تصل اي مساعدات الى
المنطقه التي انت متواجد فيها هل هنالك من
فرق اغاثيه
ما في ما اجت اجت مساعدات يعني من العالم
سندويش وما سندويش عم يوزعوه قلت لك اجتوا
بطانيات عم يبعثوا كذا العالم ما بدا
بطانيات بدها ماوى بناء
فرق اغاثيه من الدفاع المدني تواصل عمليات
الاغاثه والبحث عن احياء تحت الركام
الدفاع المدني والثاني نهار الله يجزيه
الخير اجوا والله وحتى الان موجودين عم
يطلعوا الجثث من
البنايات وكذا للساعه يعني شغالين نعم انت
الان ذكرت بانه تتواجد مع عائلتك بالسياره
تنامون بالسياره يعني ما الخطوات القادمه
يعني هل هنالك من مخيمات للاواء نصبت
اوليه
انسه عم اقول لك عم نستنى بس يا الله يبعث
لنا احد يسوي لنا دول او كذا يسوي لنا
مخيم يعمر لنا بيوت يعني مو بس انا بمئات
الالاف مثلي واكثر كمان زاد
لا احنا
جزيره شامي
سواء
التي انقاد من دون اهلها شكرا